hi reject nation Greg Alva here Andrew
here we're gonna watch the new
spider-man trailer at the e3 2018
showcase demo video I want to give a
shout out patron the day shout out to
Derek Mitchell before we get going on
this Derek Mitchell is a very kind man a
very earnest young human being who was
opening up to me messages recently I
just want to tell you Derek you are a
skilled human being and you're clearly
very kind and charming I think you just
got to increase that confidence just a
little bit I recommend all kinds of
drugs that will really help out with
that so if you're looking to get
confident don't look within look on the
outside to put something in your tongue
and then you'll gain confidence good
advice
or you could do the other way around and
actually you know develop it because
you're more than capable of being a
self-confident human being with without
trust let's watch this Spider Man Play
Station East River Super Max prison
super
that was used to drive I can't reach the
vocal radio there comes must be down
what's your status ah already here
Yuri I thought you said it was secure it
was let's go
gray crap it's not as bad as it looks
love the optimism but in my experience
what it looks back it's usually horse
woo
damn put that suit
[Music]
got her man - are you
whoa whoa I love how that just popped
like that that's cool you okay yeah
welcome to the park just in time for the
fireworks
- why is he letting everyone out I'll
head for the main control center and see
how bad the situation is it's gonna be
really bad oh here we go
lovely oh this is spider-man Arkham
Asylum and Cabos Batman game style look
at that what do you do there exactly
just webbed of just weapons
Wow at the same time multiple women
whose camera except my bit right that
Rhino
whoa you like Oh looks like a Ben
Affleck's Batman says there's a surprise
look at that camera work yeah must be
working for something this is too good
to be true
scorpion can you hold on a minute I was
in the middle of this is like spider-man
Arkham Asylum
[Music]
look at that the variety of moves you
can do here that's silly
kind of queer your salmon are working
games we can do B and above spidey-sense
yeah that's cool awesome
this feels like a brat bird made a
spider Bank here made like a while
that's it Wow whoa holy yeah I couldn't
amazing spider-man to look like this
this looks like a blast am
[Music]
Walter see this voice in this guy sounds
great
the spider-man voice of Peter yeah might
be URI ler Lowenthal that I could be
wrong that's a problem I thought you
were serious
this is like a nightmare for spider-man
right now
[Music]
[Music]
run up the wall the camera that is
awesome awesome
[Music]
oh my god that's really intense
like doesn't cut - it's all one macho
though how do you like my new suit
dashing how do you like my new soap it's
an exclusive club
it doesn't look like that I believe it
yeah
mr. negative there is already damn
love their hole at one time this is like
oh yeah damn Spidey
oh I gave that a good hit that'll hurt
he receiveth
or for heat
but he just dies
okay we got miles Perales yeah because
in this game setting up for that all
fingers there it is looks amazing man
you know what I really loved about that
trailer first off I didn't want it to
end
secondly that was legit intense like we
saw the other one last year that was
just really exciting and a lot of what
we already have sort of seen here in
terms of the gameplay the variety of
combos you can do here wide variety of
combos you can do here you mix it up
with a punch and we also mix it up with
the multiple kinds of webbing running
off and bouncing off of things when
you're attacking opponents and
everything the way the camera angles
shift that's all still fantastic this
was legit intense anybody knows me I'm
very into hand-to-hand combat and I
thought the hand and combo is awesome
like you really feel the blows ones that
Iran is hitting guys and I love how -
there's so many enemies coming at him so
you really get even though it you know
spider-man's gonna you know beat the
crap out of them you feel that threat
level in that tension knowing how many
and yeah especially when you got all the
big bad guys you know like bolter and
all them working together and mr- and
all that I love that - how they're all
working together to stop spider-man the
biggest thing that I took away from this
was I just love how he felt like
spider-man like I was just like in the
threat of danger and about to die still
making drugs and crack being a wisecrack
[Music]
it felt very organic and the jokes
really for me we're landing even in the
voice acting his voice gets more tired
as it keeps going so that was good
direction on it especially was on the
rooftop he's like it was funny stuff
this trailer gave me the only missing
element that I didn't have with the
previous one which is would I be hooked
into this in an emotional way would I be
really pulled into this in a level that
feels a strong threat or is it just
gonna be a lot of cool gameplay the
whole time even though it's primarily
gameplay it gave me a lot of fear for
Peter Parker and this I fear for
spider-man in this situation this seems
like a tough situation for him to be in
and the idea of all the people he's
worked so hard to put away are all
breaking out at once is a pretty scary
situation to be in man and I think you
said it best this is spider-man's Arkham
Asylum even though they're on the raft I
know the whole games not gonna focus
everybody just mean the setting and that
was set up here yeah yeah but I mean
look I was emotionally invested in this
I think that was the whole point like
are we gonna get emotionally invested in
this you know 7 minute clip and I did
because again like you said the moments
where you really fear at the end where
he's getting tired and he's like you
feel like he could die there I just
really was hooked like yeah they did a
great job in obviously with most new
games ps4 or Xbox one the graphics and
visuals are they look amazing they look
past four movies almost they're so good
and all the characters - all the bad
guys and I love their their looks and
things yeah mr. Nate if he looks awesome
that characters really cool from the
comics you guys should look that up that
character doesn't but again I love all
the robotic looks that they have of
their masts that they're wearing yeah
top it's gives it more of like you
turistic type of feel like and again
that kind of Iron Man where they got
that futuristic awesome kind of tackler
when I made that comment about Brad Bird
feeling he directed it
we were watching Incredibles to recently
still got to put up a review for that I
have the same thought when I watch the
first Incredibles which is this guy just
thinks of everything that would be so
cool that you could only really pull off
in an animated movie if you're doing a
superhero that's what they do here like
the there is so much movement in
everything and camera shots that
wouldn't look as good in a real-life
superhero movie to see them really
utilizing it here on PlayStation even if
you're not a big gamer I could see you
wanting to play this you know oh yeah
that's all I was thinking like the whole
time like besides being emotionally
some like I want to play this right good
spider-man story yeah alright guys well
are you still excited for this game it's
been a long time coming I am you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about the subscribe
buttons are kind of broken these days
Andrew Gordon is on the movie source
channel people check it out also check
us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A s music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron eject today I am done talking